[Music]
we're going to talk about Natalie
Portman and Jude Law answering the web's
most searched questions we're gonna talk
about how YouTube rewind 2018 is now
officially the most disliked YouTube
video of all time but first watch this
Russian robot video this is on Twitter
so they're doing this Expo trying to
show off the Soviet technology looks
pretty impressive right sure next video
Jillian okay yeah look he can dance he
can respond but show this photo that's
like he didn't even like wear a body
suit or anything I have one of those
like balaclava guys that like cover your
neck this is horrible and you know like
if you watched the dancing video he like
specifically had to be trained not to
look too human-like he's still like and
he's like slower like you know they like
put up their hands and they do this with
the robot robot take over one task in
your life what would it be
Oh literally just grab my clothes in the
morning in handy I never feel like
grabbing clothes always like I don't
know it's clothes I know just go with
the same like 5 - you know it's like
brushing teeth there's something that I
have to do every day get strokes go
ahead and I have a robot at home who
currently does exactly what I vacuum yes
I have a little room but guy gets we
have so many so much dog hair because
our dogs are petrified always as your
Chevy yeah and it's the best cuz I hate
it's perfect I didn't think about
vacuuming that's a pretty good one bad
like to have a robot work out for me
like I could like to stuff inside of it
and then it was just like yeah well then
she had a great idea next video Jillian
his rewind time yeah if I control rewind
I would want fortnight and marques
Brownlee he looks like he's dressed as
like the bad guy from that Jennifer
Lawrence movie
YouTube rewind is a show or a video that
YouTube puts out every year where they
try to show all the coolest stuff that's
happening on YouTube they've been doing
it since like 2011 but lately it's been
getting a little bit more corporate and
it's kind of like YouTube's chance to
show their sponsors like hey look what
we can do and this year it seems like
the creators finally revolted and this
has become show that image jillion the
most disliked video in 300 million
dislikes it just passed Justin Bieber's
baby which was previously the most
disliked but it took eight years for
baby to get like 9 million dislikes oh
yeah this has gotten 10 million dislikes
in a week and then people are responding
show that next image this is from the
verge it's officially the most disliked
PewDiePie did because he's not and he
was left out of it he's kind of been
snubbed because he's kind of too
controversial so that part of this would
be like a alright thing or something he
did the social experiment where you you
know I might have said some slurs or
something like go back he looks like
he's in Hunger Games which is in the
capital yeah it looks like he's in the
caffeine of the four of us you would be
the most likely to be in the capital
better than you guys you're gonna go to
a fancy party tonight and like consume
so much I'm gonna go to a fancy party
I'm gonna rub shoulders with the stars
Christmas boy I'm not a Hunger Games
monster Campbell I'm a Christmas boy The
Hunger Games monsters think of
themselves as Christmas boys though Ryan
YouTube didn't ask any of us to be in it
which is weird yeah we're on YouTube we
are on YouTube we need
[Laughter]
bring it back camera comes out camera
come back hey guys what's the most
disliked thing you've ever done that
Alex Jones episode we did was pretty bad
656 dislike yeah and then 68% dislike
ratio in terms of percentage and overall
we're less the only episode we've had a
meeting about but just like thing that
I'm done around the office is I called
one of the executives the the vice Prez
I called them Buster in the bathroom
remember that we got there like please
don't let the creator's the bathroom is
a safe space don't know networking know
networking don't call people Buster we
look very specific and everyone's like
who who would who's this - and I said
yeah who is this about who called them
Buster like a very capital move I'm
gonna network in the bath I wasn't
networking I just want you Brian is in
the capital
you've got the Mockingjay symbol that's
what's on your belt Oh
what I like boys that's Boy Scout truly
can't whistle I can't do it well I guess
that's why you're in district no one has
shares a dislike thing yeah what Natalie
Portman
what did Natalie Portman's study
psychology all right Natalie Portman
Jude Law answering the web's most
searched questions about them so now
we're gonna play that with each other in
a little game we like to call you be
Google so Natasha what did Ryan back
study Carrabba lling growling right is
that true what you study English in
Canadian Chris what does Natasha aimbot
do bake cookies with magic potions all
right yeah this was the wording on this
one's a little confusing but good answer
it best Jukka what did Chris cotton that
was one of the questions I'm doing Chris
Chris Patton what did Chris cotton Chris
cotton what I would've did how would you
answer that what didn't wait is there
one for you no we should do one for you
what does naydern eat okay what does
make durin mean okay okay okay well
first it's definitely like very well
timed creatine shakes and burritos and
burritos that's why wait
this is true Nate exercises while eating
burritos that is true it's very weird
and will go on like what a nine mile run
after a full meal of pizza and go train
your stomach to consume food while you
exercise that's not a real thing
and what does knee turn me what does
nature mean what does it mean leadership
whoa in high school I had a pair of
suspenders that said leadership Wow okay
I take it back immediately okay so those
are some of the videos this week
now Hannah's gonna tell you about the
stories you might have missed in a
little segment called cheers to you hi
I'm Hannah Dickinson this is cheers to
you where I'm kicking off my first round
of the weekend bye cheers into all the
people and stories that encouraged me to
drink cheers to you Julia Roberts for
the newspaper headline that said your
holes are getting better with age
it was obviously a typo and Julia
Roberts saw it and said no print that
cheers to youtube star yovan Hale for
making $4,000 a month in donations from
your followers how refreshing to see a
25 year old living off other people's
parents cheers to you a couple caught
having sex on top of the pyramids let's
just hope none of them injured their
stinks too
cheers to you the mom who cancelled her
baby shower when her friends hated on
her unborn son's name Squire Sebastian
senator in a Facebook post she said his
name will be a revolution and it will
push people to question everything like
should all women really have the right
to choose cheers to you a woman who
recently divorced quote a 300 year old
pirate ghost no it didn't work out
he's a pirate his whole afterlife is
about chasing the booty okay finally
ghost who's an investment banker a
lawyer get smart
cheers to you Christian Bale for saying
that after the Batman movies Donald
Trump thought he was Bruce Wayne but to
be fair so did Christian Bale cheers to
Miranda sings on giving birth to your
baby boy she plans to release the video
of the birth under her new name Miranda
screams cheers to you ABC for canceling
Dancing with the Stars before season 28
on account of running out of stars 27
seasons ago cheers to you chance
Crawford for being open to a Gossip Girl
revival as opposed to what the last
successful thing you were in was Carrie
Underwood and that was 2008 what do you
got oh my gosh I got a lot of shoutouts
today but first I need to give a sincere
apology to aviato fan o because he said
Rhinebeck as much as I admire you I have
to argue that white people are more
likely to take their cats to see Santa
Claus than dogs and he you know I was
like prove it and then he he showed me
an Instagram over 40 photos of people
with their cat that I ranted about
Christmas
so buddy I am sorry and then we have a
couple other shots yesterday along this
episode
Kyle Amoroso had a nice fun game he said
the last digit of the of your like is
who you are so he's talking about his
comment and it was the options were one
for Nate two for Natasha three for Chris
four for Hannah five for Jordan six for
Ryan seven for Ryan's dog eight for
nametag Terry shoutout to our sketch
series make sure to check that out 9 the
director whose name is and then 0 for
Jillian
[Laughter]
so thanks for all the shoutouts write
something in the comments today and
we'll talk about it at some point all
right one more piece of news this week
post Malone made his own pair of Crocs
they sold out in ten seconds this is
actually the second time he's made a
pair of Crocs and so our very own jordan
mendoza decided to make a pair to see if
he could imitate watch this right now
[Applause]
I'm headed to Crocs on 34th Street to
buy some Crocs and DIY yes I know
they're sold out but I am DIY in the
post Malone Crocs collaboration wish me
luck
Chris what do you think about all this
okay isn't that cool
sure pretty cool huh hey Ryan you notice
anything cool or new about me oh yeah
you made um you made trying to do like
you just ruined a pair of Crocs
[Music]
you